hi I'm Leslie I'm a blogger and if you
want to know how to get this glittery
festival look keep watching to start
upon my face with the benefit poor
professional and pearl primer apply this
with my fingers all over my face and rub
in the foundation I like the NARS
natural radiant long wear foundation I'm
dotting this all over my face before
blending in with my fingertips I think
I'm in with a little concealer I'm using
Too Faced Born This Way naturally
radiant concealer and I dub this over
any areas I want to brighten
I'm keeping my brows soft and natural so
for this I love the Estee Lauder
Brownell volumizing brighten I brush
this over my brow starting at the edge
and working my way out following the
natural shape of my brows to add a
little warmth on the cheeks I'm using
the smashbox kelley contour palette i
applied a matte bronzer shade first with
a bronzing brush and then I add the
matte blush shade to add some color
to highlight I love the Naz Eliminator
in Copacabana this is one of my favorite
highlights and I love to use this on the
tops of my cheekbones and my eyebrow
bone now for the fun part I'm using NYX
glitter in bronze to buy and lumi light
so one of my hacks we're getting the
glitter to stick is using a lip balm I'm
using the LA no lips
101 appointment multi balm so you can
either apply this with a brush or use
your finger to dap then i go in with a
glitter i love mixing two shades
together to give it more dimension to
finish this glittery eye i love adding
stars to really make this look pop don't
forget to add definition I'm using the
Smashbox super fan fanned out mascara
finally to finish this festival look I'm
using Too Faced melted chocolate on my
lips I love the shimmer and it smells
amazing for more videos like this
subscribe to glamour UK's YouTube
channel